- Okay, let's go down memory lane.
- The topic today is an adversary
that poses a threat, serious threat
to the security of the
United States of America.
This adversary is one of
the world's last bastions
of central planning, governs
by dictating five-year plans.
With single capital, it attempts
to impose its command across time zones,
continents, oceans, and beyond.
With brutal consistency,
it stifles free thought
and crushes new ideas.
Perhaps this adversary sounds
like the former Soviet Union,
but that enemy's gone.
The adversary's closer to home.
It's the Pentagon bureaucracy.
We must transform the
way the department works
and what it works on.
Our challenge is to
transform not just the way
we deter and defend,
but the way we conduct
our daily business.
We know the adversary, we know the threat,
and with the same firmness of purpose
that any effort against a
determined adversary demands,
we must get at it and stay at it.
Some might ask, how in the world could
the Secretary of Defense
attack the Pentagon
in front of its people?
To them, I reply I have no
desire to attack the Pentagon.
I want to liberate it.
We need to save it from itself.
And that means we must recognize
another transformation,
the revolution in management, technology,
and business practices.
Successful modern businesses are leaner
and less hierarchical than ever before.
They reward innovation,
and they share information.
They have to be nimble in
the face of rapid change,
or they die.
Business enterprises die
if they fail to adapt.
And the fact that they can fail and die
is what provides the incentive to survive.
But governments can't die,
so we need to find other incentives
for bureaucracy to adapt and improve.
Already, we've made some progress.
We've eliminated some 31
of the 72 acquisition-related
advisory boards.
We now budget based on
realistic estimates.
We're improving the acquisition process.
We're investing $400 million
in public-private partnerships
for military housing.
Many utility services to
military installations
will be privatized.
We have committed $100 million
for financial modernization,
and we're establishing
a Defense Business Board
to tap outside expertise
as we move to improve
the department's business practices.
To transform the department,
we must look outside
this building as well.
Consequently, the senior executive council
will scour the department for functions
that could be performed
better and more cheaply
through commercial outsourcing.
Like the private sector's
best-in-class companies,
DOD should aim for excellence in functions
that are either directly
related to war fighting
or must be performed by the department.
But in all other cases,
we should seek suppliers
who can provide these non-core activities
efficiently and effectively.
We have brought people on board
who have driven similar
change in the private sector.
We intend to do so here.
The old adage that you
get what you inspect,
not what you expect, or put differently,
that what you measure improves, is true.
It is powerful, and we will be measuring.
- So that was Secretary
of Defense Donald Rumsfeld
in a speech at the Pentagon.
As it turned out, on the
10th of September, 2001.
(audience laughing)
And as you can tell,
he's elaborating on the agenda
that we've already discussed
at length in this course
about privatization
of military functions without any idea
about what's about to hit the country.
He's not only talking about outsourcing
and privatizing, but he
really came into the Pentagon
with a mandate to completely reorganize it
along management principles
that were deployed
in the private sector.
And he was busily
setting about that agenda
in the first months and first
year of the administration.
But, of course, 10 days later,
America was very differently preoccupied.
- Our enemy is a radical
network of terrorists,
and every government that supports them.
(audience applause)
Our war on terror begins with Al-Qaeda,
but it does not end there.
It will not end until every
terrorist group of global reach
has been found, stopped, and defeated.
(audience applause)
These terrorists kill
not merely to end lives
but to disrupt and end a way of life.
With every atrocity, they hope
that America grows fearful,
retreating from the world
and forsaking our friends.
They stand against us because
we stand in their way.
We have seen their kind before.
They are the heirs of all
the murderous ideologies
of the 20th century.
By sacrificing human life to
serve their radical visions,
by abandoning every value
except the will to power,
they follow in the path
of fascism, Nazism,
and totalitarianism, and
they will follow that path
all the way to where it ends,
in history's unmarked
grave of discarded lives.
(audience applause)
Americans are asking, how will
we fight and win this war?
We will direct every
resource at our command,
every means of diplomacy,
every tool of intelligence,
every instrument of law enforcement,
every financial influence,
and every necessary weapon
of war to the disruption
and to the defeat of the
global terror network.
Now, this war will not be
like the war against Iraq
a decade ago with a decisive liberation
of territory and a swift conclusion.
It will not look like the air
war above Kosovo two years ago
where no ground troops were used
and not a single American
was lost in combat.
Our response involves far
more than instant retaliation
and isolated strikes.
Americans should not expect one battle
but a lengthy campaign unlike
any other we have ever seen.
It may include dramatic
strikes visible on TV
and covert operations,
secret even in success.
We will starve terrorists of funding,
turn them one against another,
drive them from place to place
until there is no refuge or no rest,
and we will pursue
nations that provide aid
or safe haven to terrorism.
Every nation in every region
now has a decision to make,
either you are with us or
you are with the terrorists.
(audience applause)
- That was President Bush's
statement to the nation,
the 20th of September, nine
days after the 9/11 attacks,
and it denounced the advent
of what we have come since
to refer to as the Global War
on Terrorism, or the GWOT.
And today, this agenda is
gonna be to explore that.
We're gonna talk about what was the GWOT,
and what is it?
What has it become?
We're gonna ask how radical
an innovation was it,
and what did it mean for the emerging
post-Cold War international
order that we talked about
in the very first lecture of the course?
And finally, I want us to also think about
as we go through this material,
what were the paths not taken?
What might have been done differently
that might leave us in
a different position
than we are today?
Let's think back to the 1991 Gulf War
that I lectured about at
the beginning of the course.
And particularly, George
Herbert Walker Bush,
Bush 41, as some like to call him,
what strategy he pursued
when Saddam Hussein
invaded Kuwait in December of 1990.
And this strategy of pursuit
had a number of elements.
One was that it was fully authorized
through the UN Security Council.
Resolutions were passed admonishing
Saddam Hussein to leave Kuwait,
which he ignored and
eventually stonewalled
but refused to comply with.
Secondly, the Bush 41 Administration
put together a very large
and diverse coalition,
which included participants
with many different
geostrategic interests,
including every Arab nation
except Jordan participated
in that coalition.
They stuck to the limited authorized goal
of expelling Saddam Hussein from Kuwait
and made no effort at
regime change in Iraq.
This is something for which
Bush was heavily criticized
by neoconservatives in the US.
We'll hear more about
neoconservatism next week.
And many people thought he
was being too much of a wimp
and that once you had half
a million troops there,
that he should have gone
all the way to Baghdad
and interestingly, Dick Cheney,
who was in that administration,
came out as a strong defender
of not doing that, partly on the grounds
that we wouldn't know
what, we wouldn't be able
to manage the system,
the situation thereafter,
this philosophy that if
you break it, you own it,
which, again, we will
attend to more next week.
But it was this basic idea
that Bush was operating on of,
that I like to call stop the
bully without becoming a bully.
Then the notion was that if people engage
in aggression across borders,
the international
community will stop them.
But it was consistent with
the UN Charter's commitment
to the maintenance of
international peace and security,
which is a line in the UN Charter,
which we saw has come to be questioned
subsequently with the implementation
of responsibility to protect, for example.
But at the time, it was seen
as a sacrosanct commitment
of the UN, essentially to protect
the status quo of the division
of the world into nations.
And so you stop aggression,
but you don't engage
in regime change, and you don't rearrange
the global geography.
Over this and the next two lectures,
I want people to think
about one counterfactual.
This is not the only one,
but what if that had become the template
for facing down international aggression
in the post-Cold War world?
And that was clearly
part of Bush 41's agenda.
He wanted to etch these norms
into accepted common law
practice if you like,
of international conduct
and also the notion
that they should all be mediated
through the United Nations.
Another way of putting it is that he had
a kind of containment sensibility,
George Herbert Walker Bush.
The idea was to contain aggression,
not to solve the world's
problems, not to end bad regimes,
but to contain aggression,
to stop aggression.
And of course, the word
containment has a long history.
It goes back to the Cold War,
and I wanna take us back
through that history
because it's really only
by having some sense
of that history that we
can evaluate the extent
of the departure that comes
with the Global War on Terror
a decade after Bush, Sr. was doing this.
If we think back, the idea
of containment, of course,
was articulated by George Kennan in 1946
in something which was
called the long telegram.
He was in Moscow at the time as part
of the Truman Administration.
And it was published
subsequently anonymously
with the authorship X as a document
in "Foreign Affairs" the next year,
it called the Sources of Soviet Conduct.
And this is the classic statement
of the original idea of containment.
And it had a number of elements to it,
the original doctrine of containment,
as conceived by Kennan.
Kennan, first and foremost,
he was a staunchly anticommunist,
very conservative and indeed held views
about race and other matters
which would not endear him
to many people in this room.
Be that as it may, this was
his view of the Soviet Union.
He thought it was, first of all,
fundamentally antithetical
to Western democracy,
and he thought the enterprise
of getting involved
in public debates with the
Soviets about capitalism
versus communism and the desirability
of different systems, was
a total waste of time.
There was no possibility of dialogue,
and he didn't advocate, he
thought it was just pointless
and indeed, might give propaganda
victories to the Soviets
in the developing world
during the Cold War.
But secondly, he was absolutely
unequivocally convinced
that the Soviet Union was unsustainable,
that it was a flawed economic
system for the reasons
that we know well, that command
economies don't really work,
and that eventually it would develop
the kinds of problems
that it eventually did.
But then secondly, and actually in this,
he was stating something
that has since become
conventional wisdom among
political economists
who study international relations,
he was convinced that the Soviet
Union's hegemonic ambitions
would bankrupt them, that
as they sought to become
a hegemonic power, they would
be spending more and more
sustaining that hegemony, and eventually
it would drive them to ruin.
And as I say, it is
conventional wisdom now
in the international relations field,
made famous by people
like Stephen Krasner,
Robert Keohane, and others
that hegemonic powers
become overextended and
eventually find it very difficult
to sustain the financing
of their hegemony.
Kennan was contemptuous
of all political science
and social science.
He wouldn't put it in those terms, but
his seat-of-the-pants judgment
was that this was a system
that was just gonna
drive itself off a cliff.
Then what should the US do?
And here, Kennan's view was,
well the US should forget
about the governments
in the Soviet Union and really focus
its attention on the populations
behind the Iron Curtain,
essentially to win the
battle for hearts and minds.
The thought was that as these systems
became more and more dysfunctional,
people would be more and more dissatisfied
and then it would be
important, first of all,
for them to see successful
models elsewhere.
And so he thought it was hugely important
to rebuild the American
domestic economy at home
and to invest in rebuilding
Western Europe and Japan,
so a huge supporter of the Marshall Plan,
no doubt partly because of commitment
to the West European countries,
but from the point of view
of his containment doctrine,
the idea was that as the
populations behind the Iron Curtain
experienced increasing levels of poverty
and disaffection from their regimes,
they would see on television
and learn about in other ways,
the thriving democratic
systems in the West.
The other side of that
coin was he very much
wanted to admonish, first and foremost,
the Truman Administration,
but subsequent American administrations
and Western governments, not to start
to become like the Soviet Union.
We needed to not behave in ways
that would make us seem
to be their moral equal.
We should, therefore, maintain
civil liberties at home
and in our international conduct.
We shouldn't engage in adventurism.
Essentially, our goal should be
about containing Soviet aggression.
And he thought the principle
means of doing that
would be economic and diplomatic.
He was opposed to the
formation of NATO, for example.
He thought creating NATO
would just militarize
the confrontation between
us and the Warsaw Pact,
and if we created NATO, the
Soviets would do something
comparable on the other
side, which they did.
He opposed the Vietnam War.
This is much later, of course,
but again, on the theory
that this is about something
more aggressive than containment.
The Vietnam War was
motivated by a domino theory
that if Vietnam was allowed to fall,
then the whole of the
rest of Southeast Asia
would go communist, none of
which turned out to be true.
And he was, part of the reason that he
was opposed to Vietnam
War was quite prescient,
which is that if, in his mind,
if you are fighting a war of choice
against an enemy for whom
it's an existential war,
unless you can have a very
quick, cheap, easy victory,
as when Ronald Reagan invaded Grenada
or something of that
order, basically the cards
are stacked against you because you're not
gonna be able to sustain support at home
for a war of choice.
Whereas your adversary isn't fighting
for their very existence,
and so they will be able
to sustain support.
So he was very skeptical of conflicts
like the Vietnam War, which he
thought was a giant mistake.
That was classical containment doctrine
as articulated by Kennan.
And it didn't get very far.
Indeed, he rapidly got into conflict
with the Truman Administration.
And the Truman Doctrine,
as I've already intimated,
was revolved around
militarizing the standoff
with the Soviets in ways
that Kennan didn't like.
And this was laid out in a document
called the NSC 68, published in 1950.
Many scholars call it
the most important US strategic statement
of US principles during the Cold War,
and it was essentially laid out
what's come to be known
as the Truman Doctrine.
And it supported the creation of NATO,
and it supported a much
more aggressive stance.
Now, some scholars still
call it containment,
so John Lewis Gaddis in his excellent book
"Strategies of Containment",
calls this a different
kind of containment.
And I don't have anything
invested in the terminology,
but it's a much more militarized
version of containment
than Kennan originally envisaged.
For Kennan, military
force should always be
a strategy of last resort, not
a strategy of first resort.
You try everything else first,
and you only use it, you use it sparingly
to stop aggression when you have to.
Even during the Truman Administration,
Kennan had all this conflict,
and eventually he stormed off in a huff
to the Institute for
Advanced Study at Princeton
where he spent the next several decades,
occasionally throwing spitballs
at one administration after another.
He became a grumpy old man of sorts.
But, of course, the Truman Administration
was just the beginning of the Cold War.
And then we had the
Eisenhower Administration,
and the Eisenhower Administration took
a more militaristic view
of US foreign policy
than even the militarized version
of containment that was
embedded in the Truman Doctrine.
And so, the Eisenhower
comes to power in 1952.
The Cold War's ramping up.
McCarthyism is ramping up.
And proponents of containment get accused
of being proponents of appeasement,
that this is all about appeasement.
And, of course, appeasement
is actually giving in
to foreign aggression in the way
that the British and French did
when Hitler was beginning
his expansionist policies
and then accepting them.
Containment is not, it's not that.
Containment says you do respond
to actual attempts at aggression.
But short of that, you
don't involve yourself
in trying to rewrite
global political geography.
And so, John Foster Dulles
who was the John Bolton
of his era, you might say, he
was the proponent of rollback.
And rollback was to not accept
the disposition, particularly of Europe,
after the Iron Curtain came down,
and that he thought we
really needed to push back
against the Soviet Union
much more aggressively
than any notion of
containment would suggest.
And indeed, Eisenhower ran on
rollback in the 1952 election
saying that they would take
a much more aggressive,
anticommunist stance
than the Truman Administration had done.
Interestingly enough,
of course, at that time,
the Truman Administration was bogged down
in the Korean War, which
Eisenhower promptly
negotiated a settlement to
after not very long in office.
But, in any event, they ran on rollback,
and, of course, something like rollback
was became a much more dominant theme
if we think about the
Johnson Administration
during Vietnam and Nixon.
Nixon's strategy became more complicated
than just straightforward rollback
because he wanted to, actually
in true Kennanesque fashion,
he wanted to exploit divisions
among communist regimes.
That's part of what the
opening to China was about,
but nonetheless, in
prosecuting the Vietnam War,
at least as he did and in
the era before detente,
he was something of hawk with
respect to the Soviet Union.
That was rollback, and interestingly,
when we think about, we
look back on the Cold War,
despite what Eisenhower ran in in 1952
and what Dulles came
into the State Department
attempting to do, he
found a lot of pushback
against rollback in the State Department
and found that many people were actually
more convinced, if not of
Kennan's version of containment,
at least they were convinced
of the Truman Doctrine's version of it.
In Europe, the US largely did stick
to containment as its policy.
They didn't really their to rollback
the frontiers of the Soviet empire.
And if you look at where
they did try to rollback
the frontiers of the Soviet empire,
such as in Iran where there
was an election in 1953
and a pro-Soviet government was elected,
we went in and toppled that government
and basically implanted the Shah.
Didn't turn out that well.
We engaged in rollback in Vietnam.
By the end of the Cold War, containment
and indeed Kennan was
given a lot of credit
as a policy that had actually worked.
Of course, where that
containment would have worked
in the absence of NATO is a question
to which we'll never have an answer.
Whether it was the
Kennanesque version of it
or the Truman Doctrine version of it,
nonetheless, it was given great credit,
partly because the early predictions
had turned out to be right.
The economy was unsustainable,
and the Soviet Union did
indeed become bankrupt,
partly because of Reagan's Star Wars,
which spent them, created
not just an arms race
for space weapons, but a dollars race.
And then, of course, very
relevant to today's discussion,
they got embroiled in an
unwinnable war in Afghanistan,
which turned out to be
the Soviet's Vietnam,
interestingly, also
motivated by a domino theory.
The Soviet belief was
that if the Mujahedin
succeeded in Afghanistan, this would allow
Islamic fundamentalism to start working
its way through the Asiatic republics
of the Soviet Union, and
it had to be stopped.
Of course, when the dominoes
finally started falling,
it was in Western Europe,
and it had nothing
to do with Afghanistan.
George Herbert Walker
Bush's policy in 1990,
the first Gulf War, is really
a version of containment
as mediated through
international institutions.
Kennan was a hard-boiled realist,
and so he had no time for the UN
and part of the reason
he had no time for NATO,
by the way, was, again,
his hard-boiled realism,
he said, "No nation is gonna
bind itself by an alliance,
"if it's not in their interest to do it."
It's either gonna be
irrelevant when it's needed
or window dressing when it's not.
But he also thought no nation was gonna
pay any attention to the UN.
So that aspect of Kennan's thinking
is not part of the post-Cold
War containment idea
that Bush was working to entrench
in the way that he responded
to the first Gulf War in 1991.
Now, let's come to Bush
43's Global War on Terror
and what came to be called the
Bush Doctrine very rapidly.
And we can see what we
think about how it contrasts
with what had gone before.
The first feature of the Bush Doctrine
is that he envisages it as
being worldwide in scope.
He says, "We will strike anywhere,
"and we reserve the
right to strike anywhere
"if there is a threat to
our national security."
Now, of course, America's
assertion of unilateral rights
to strike perceived threats that were not
to the American mainland
has a long history.
In fact, goes back to 1823
when John Quincy Adams
articulated what came to
known as the Monroe Doctrine;
although, it didn't actually get named
the Monroe Doctrine until
some decades later in 1850.
But it was the Monroe
Administration asserted
that any European interference anywhere
in Latin America would be conceived of
and responded to as a threat
to the national security
of the United States.
And so, essentially, during
the Monroe Doctrine said
that we control the hemisphere,
and anybody who interferes
in the hemisphere
is interfering with
America's national interests,
and we will respond with force.
That was aimed at the
Europeans in the 19th century,
but it is the precedent, if you like,
to the extent there is a precedent
for George W. Bush asserting,
we will act militarily
anywhere in the world
if our national security is threatened.
And indeed, interestingly, he talked
about the Axis of Evil,
Iran, Iraq, and North Korea.
And of course, in those days,
Iraq was not an Islamic administration.
It was a secular Baathist
regime, run by Saddam Hussein.
Iran was an Islamic state,
and North Korea was communist state.
And so he was, by putting
those three together
as the Axis of Evil, he
was doing two things.
One was he was saying, and this was
the Bush Administration's
position until 2006,
that is not about Islamic fundamentalism.
That terrorism is, and he was very careful
not to attack the idea of
Islamic fundamentalism.
The War on Terror was
not just about Islam.
It changes that rhetoric after 2006,
but also, that we would
act anywhere in the world.
And if you think about Phnom Penh,
it's 12 time zones away from
east coast United States,
so the only way you could get further away
would be by blasting off into space.
(audience laughs)
Now, we've taken the
Monroe Doctrine worldwide.
Secondly, we asserted the
right to act unilaterally,
unconstrained by any existing alliances
and unconstrained by what
international institution
might or might not authorize.
And indeed, this is where
he coined the phrase,
coalitions of the willing.
We will put together coalitions
on a opportunistic basis if necessary
to fight our adversaries.
And indeed, as I mentioned
to you in an earlier lecture,
one of the reasons so many
East European countries
were added to NATO in the 2004 and 2005
was it was the quid pro
quo for their promise
to participate in the Iraq invasion
that I'll be talking about next week.
We can act unilaterally with allies
that are willing to
form coalitions with us.
We're not constrained, either by alliances
or by international institutions.
Third, he asserted a right
to engage in preemptive war.
The traditional justification of war
was the existence of an imminent threat.
Word imminent has a long history.
It's partly connected to just war theory,
which says that an imminent
threat is necessary
for war to count as a just war.
And if you go back and
actually read the NSC 68,
the statement of the Truman Doctrine
published in 1950, it asserts there
that the US will never
engage in preemptive war,
that it's only gonna act defensively.
Very quickly, the Bush
Administration said, no.
We are not gonna be constrained
by the doctrine of imminent threats.
And they started talking about
things like emerging threats,
gathering threats, would be sufficient
to justify American military action.
And of course, if you
think about that doctrine,
a doctrine of emerging threats,
you then are almost inevitably
also gonna get away from the idea
that we're only getting involved
in wars of existential survival.
You're gonna be back in
the world of optional wars
because there's no clear
sense in which emerging
or gathering can be neatly calibrated
or that you can convince your citizenry
of the importance of an
emerging or a gathering threat.
That's part of what we
have with global warming.
It's a gathering threat.
It's an emerging threat.
You can't, much harder to mobilize people
for a chronic problem, if
you like, than a crisis.
Eminent war was thrown out of the window
in favor of these notions
of gathering threats,
emerging threats, and so on.
Again, we can engage in preemptive wars
against emerging or gathering threats.
In that Bush doctrine,
as he articulated it,
first at West Point commencement address
in June of 2002 and then reiterated it
in two national security
statement doctrines
that the Bush Administration published,
one later that year and
then reaffirmed in 2006.
They said, a legitimate war
aim was now regime change.
A legitimate war aim was to get rid
of an oppressive dictatorship.
Completely out of the window,
the UN notion that international action
is legitimate if its goal is to restore
the status quo ante of
an international borders,
but simply if a regime is
sufficiently oppressive,
vis a vis its own population,
this will be a justification
for military action.
And the reason they
articulated this so early
was they already had their eye on Iraq.
It was very clear, for reasons
we'll get to next week,
that from the beginning,
the administration
was committed to removing
Saddam Hussein from power
even before we had started
the battle in Afghanistan.
A fifth element of the Bush Doctrine was,
again, a very radical departure,
which was that there's no
possibility of neutrality.
As he put it at the end
of the clip I showed you,
"if you're not with us,
you're with the terrorists."
And of course, there had
been a long tradition
of neutrality in international relations.
If you go back to the
US in the 19th century,
we had often asserted neutrality,
and if you come even
into the 20th century,
if you look in the run-up to World War II,
Congress was passing
neutrality legislation
hand over fist to keep FDR
out of the war with Germany
in the late 1930s.
So there was a long tradition of the US
asserting the right to be neutral
in international conflicts
and during the Cold War,
the non-aligned nations
had declared themselves to be neutral
in the conflict between
the US and the Soviets.
Once we get to the Bush Doctrine,
all of that also goes out of the window.
Essentially, we're now
declaring to the world that
if you do not support
us, we will feel free
to interpret that as
support for our adversaries,
and we will act accordingly.
Finally, the Bush Doctrine,
as he indicated in that clip,
envisages, if not permanent war,
a war that we can never really
say has finally been won.
We're declaring war on terror.
Well, there's been terrorism in the world
since the beginning of time.
And so the idea that you're now gonna be
on a war footing so long
as there is terrorism
in the world, you're essentially saying
the US economy is gonna be
on a permanent war footing.
We're gonna be engaging in what
have since come to be called
endless wars into the indefinite future.
Some have said that the Bush Doctrine
was not that radical of an
innovation, but clearly it was.
It was much more radical than anything
that had gone before.
And it, of course, what it did was
as it has played out, and we'll see this
in the next two lectures, it completely
rubbished his father's attempt to re-embed
some notion of containment
for a post-Cold War era
into international politics,
and it's one reason his father
was very critical of him and
of Cheney and of Rumsfeld
for, if you like, scuttling his legacy.
And this came out in a
subsequent biography.
In effect, the Bush Doctrine,
if you wanted a bumper sticker for it,
is rollback of all possible adversaries
at any time and in any place.
The US now asserts the right to do that.
It was about as radical an innovation
as one could have come up with.
And certainly, the most radical innovation
in US national security policy
in the history of the republic.
Now, let's turn to the Afghan conflict.
One question is, well, why was Al-Qaeda
based in Afghanistan in the first place?
And you already know.
Why were they there?
They just popped up.
Osama bin Laden had a long
and antagonistic history
of not very good relations
with his Saudi government.
He was a Saudi Arabian citizen,
and he had become radicalized and had,
in the 1980s, worked with the Mujahidin
in Afghanistan, helping
them battle the Soviets.
And when the Soviet
Union finally collapsed,
he had tried to mediate an end
to the ongoing war in Afghanistan
among the militias, not with much success.
He had been bounced around the Middle East
and eventually wound up in Sudan.
During the invasion of
Kuwait by Saddam Hussein
that I was talking about some minutes ago,
he was strongly of the opinion
that the Saudis, first
of all, in that war,
part of the reason there
was so much anxiety
about Saddam Hussein's invasion of Kuwait,
was people thought Saudi
Arabia will be next.
And Saudi Arabia is a huge
supplier of oil to the West,
so there's both the Saudis themselves
and others is part the reason
there was Arab participation
in the coalition to get
Saddam out of Kuwait.
Bin Laden said that on no
account should the Saudis
accept Western participation
in expelling Saddam Hussein
from Kuwait, and if they did,
they would be inviting the infidel
into the heart of the Middle East.
And they ignored him, and then he kept up
a steady stream of attacks
on the Saudi regime
in print and verbally and
was increasingly suspective
also of even financing terrorist attacks
in Saudi Arabia from his bases in Sudan
and elsewhere that he moved around to.
The Saudis finally,
they first banished him
from the country and then stripped him
of his Saudi citizenship.
I think that was in 1994
they had stripped him
of his citizenship, and eventually,
they started putting pressure on Sudan
to kick him out of Sudan
because they thought he was,
an ambassador to the Americans
think he was using this
as a base for mounting terrorist attacks,
which were ramping up over the 1990s.
Finally, the Saudis agreed
and everybody agreed
that they would leave him alone
if he would go to Afghanistan,
and there was a sort of
tacit acknowledgement
that he would not foment terrorism
within Saudi Arabia from that base.
But as Al-Qaeda became
increasingly radicalized,
we should remember that
their two primary war aims
were, first, to overthrow
the Saudi regime,
and secondly, to get the
West out of the Middle East.
It was what they, at that
time, called a defensive jihad,
rather than an offensive jihad,
which they had subsequently embraced.
That's why he was in Afghanistan.
And that's why the 9/11 attacks
were plotted from Afghanistan.
He had good relations
with the Taliban regime
of Mullah Omar.
They had worked together
there in the 1980s.
An important thing to
say about the Afghan war
is we very early on made a decision
to pursue regime change.
Basically, what happened
was we went to the UN,
we said, we got resolutions passed saying
the Taliban must turn over Osama bin Laden
and close down the training camps.
They refused, and we essentially said,
we're gonna wipe you out.
We're gonna take over your regime.
But, and here, this is part of the reason
I showed you the Rumsfeld clip
at the beginning of the lecture,
it turns out that when Rumsfeld said,
we'll contract out everything
except core military capacities,
that was not an accurate statement
because the Bush
Administration was certainly
not interested in growing the military.
Indeed, Rumsfeld was
shrinking the military.
And they had no intention
of changing that.
They wanted to attack Afghanistan,
and they wanted to do it
largely by contracting out,
not to military contractors
as we talked about
in the privatization lecture,
that would come later.
But they thought the way to do this
since Afghanistan was in
the midst of a civil war,
the way to do this was to get behind
one of the belligerents in the civil war
and let them take over the country,
and then they will be friendly regime.
The belligerent in question was a group
called the Northern Alliance,
and the Northern Alliance
was losing the war.
They had been pushed into a
small corner of the country,
and but for us, involvement with them
and support for them, they
would almost certainly
have been defeated in
relatively short order.
What we did was we got
behind the Northern Alliance
and supported them in
the Afghan civil war,
which led then to the
destruction of the regime,
which was in two important respects,
a setup for failure for two reasons.
One is the theoretical expectation,
maybe it's dressing it up too much
to call it theoretical, but at least,
one should have skeptical priors.
If you get behind the
losing side in a civil war,
the odds are its gonna be very difficult
for them to govern if
you put them in power
because one of the reasons
they're the losing side
in a war is they probably don't have
much grassroots support on the ground.
And we will see this
play out again in Libya
and elsewhere in upcoming lectures.
There were good reasons
for skepticism of the idea
that this was a good way to
put in a puppet government
that would be friendly to the US
and be able to govern the country
without massive infusions of support.
And, of course, nobody anticipated
for a second that we would
make Marshall Plan type
of investments in
Afghanistan in 2001 and 2002.
The notion we were gonna
sustain the rebuilding
of this country was not
on anybody's scanner,
and indeed, as we have
subsequently tried to do it,
that has been a dramatic failure.
There was no postwar planning of any kind.
This was in the heat
of the weeks after 9/11
and the notion was that this horrific evil
has been perpetrated
against the United States,
and we're gonna go there
and take care of business!
I mean, that was the dominant
rhetoric behind this invasion.
One question to ask is,
might we have done any
of this differently?
Was there a path not taken here?
Clearly, we, as I said in the chapters
I had you read today, the
idea of responding to 9/11
through the lens of the
criminal justice system
was a complete nonstarter
given the scale and scope
of the attacks, and there was gonna be
a military response.
And it was also clearly the case that
once the Taliban regime
refused to be cooperative,
there was gonna be military action.
Well, there was a path not taken
advocated by some at the time.
And this is summarized
by Lawrence Wilkerson
who was Colin Powell's chief of staff.
In an interview in "The
Cairo Review" five years ago,
he said, "The smart strategy,
"and there were those who
advocated this at the time,"
and he's correct about that.
You can find it in the archival evidence.
"Was to go in, pound the
hell out of Al-Qaeda,
"try to get bin Laden and his leadership.
"If you didn't, so be it.
"You'd keep hunting.
"You'd do it mostly with
special ops forces and the CIA.
"You would pound the Taliban a little bit,
"and as you left you'd tell them,
"'Do it again, and we'll do it again.'
"This was very formidable, persuasive,
"strategic brief, and the
president rejected it."
Then he says in a rather mean aside,
"Well, really the vice
president rejected it."
Because it was common knowledge
that Cheney was really the brains behind
and certainly the energy behind the war
as it was being fought.
What would have been the advantages
of such an approach?
Essentially you would ignore the Taliban.
You would say, we've been
attacked by these people,
and we're gonna go after them,
and we are going to destroy them.
And if you interfere with us,
good luck with that because
we will beat you up, too.
And they need not have
engaged in regime change,
particularly if you're
thinking about a world
in which you're gonna be acting
with a light footprint and wanting
to keep your forces available
for deployment anywhere,
seems like it might be a way to go.
Obviously, first of all, much cheaper,
vastly cheaper than replacing a regime.
You finance your operation,
and then when you leave,
you leave with your operation.
Secondly, it avoids the you
break it, you own it problem.
If you create a failed state,
you are then saddled with a failed state,
and you've gotta administer a failed state
or at least support some side
that's trying to
administer a failed state.
By toppling the regime,
we took on a much bigger set of problems.
Now some might say, well,
what about the costs
in terms of deterrence,
that you want other players
around the world to know that
if they support terrorists
or allow terrorists
in their country, they're
gonna be wiped out, too?
That might have been some of the thinking,
but I suspect the real
reasons it was not done,
first of all, the raids after 9/11,
the idea that in the weeks and
months following that attack,
the notion that Mullah Omar's
regime was thumbing their nose
at the US, was just too much to bear
and too much politically to tolerate,
as well as hubris about what
could be achieved in Afghanistan.
And here, we tend
to repeat the mistakes of history.
You didn't have to go
back to the 19th century
and Britain's failed attempts
to subdue Afghanistan.
The Americans had watched in real time
for a decade as the Soviets
had been ground down
in the Afghan mountains.
It's about the worse
possible terrain in the world
for military campaigns.
It's not really surprising perhaps
that we didn't pursue that path,
but certainly, there
were people on the ground
advocating it, and it's
something that we didn't do.
What did we do, apart
from toppling the regime?
What did we do in going after bin Laden?
And what we did came
to a head in December,
in northeastern Syria in what,
in northeastern Afghanistan, in these,
very high up in the
mountains in a remote area
called Tora Bora, the Battle of Tora Bora,
which was conducted over the
middle of December of 2001.
And here's some commentary
from a key player
at the Battle of Tora Bora.
- [Scott] Following
the strategy of keeping
an Afghan face on the war,
Fury's Delta Team joined the CIA
and Afghan fighters and
piled into pickup trucks.
They videotaped their journey
to a place called Tora Bora.
Fury told us his orders
were to kill bin Laden,
and leave the body with the Afghans.
- Right here, you're looking at,
basically the battlefield
from the last location
that we had firm on Osama
bin Laden's location.
- This ridge line, is
it about 14,000 feet?
And back this way toward me is Pakistan.
- [Dalton] That's right.
- On a scale of say, one to
10, 10 being the toughest,
how tough a position is this to attack?
- (laughs) In my experience, it's a 10.
- [Scott] Delta developed
an audacious plan
to come at bin Laden
from the one direction
he would never expect.
- And we wanna come in on the back door.
- You were gonna come up
over the tops of the peaks?
- That's right, the original
plan that we sent up
to our higher headquarters,
Delta Force wants to come in,
over the mountain with oxygen,
coming from the Pakistan
side, over the mountains
and come and get a drop
on bin Laden from behind.
- Why didn't you do that?
- Disapproved at some level above us,
whether that was central command,
all the way up to the
President of the United States,
I'm not sure.
- [Scott] The next option,
Delta wanted to employ
was to drop hundreds of land mines
in the mountain passes
that led to Pakistan,
bin Laden's escape route.
- First guy blows his leg off.
Everybody else stops.
That allows aircraft
overhead to find them.
They see all these heat sources out there.
Okay, there's a big large
group of Al-Qaeda moving south.
They can engage that.
- Why didn't you do that?
- Disapproved.
- [Scott] Why was it not approved?
- I have no idea.
- How often does Delta come
up with a tactical plan
that's disapproved by higher headquarters?
- In my experience, in my five
years at Delta, never before.
- The military wouldn't tell us
who rejected the plans or why.
Fury wasn't happy about it,
but he pressed on with the
only option he had left,
a frontal assault on bin Laden's
dug in Al-Qaeda fighters.
The Delta Team had only about 50 men,
so the mission would depend
on the Afghan militia
as guides and muscle.
Their leader was a warlord, a
self-styled general named Ali.
Ali, second from the left,
met with this CIA officer
and accepted millions of
dollars in cash from the agency.
Dressed like Afghans,
the Americans maneuvered
up the mountains, calling
in airstrikes on Al-Qaeda.
By day, they would advance, but at night,
they soon discovered that
their Afghan allies went home.
Well, I have to assume
that if you started up
the hills of Tora Bora, and
the Mujahedin took territory,
they didn't abandon that at night.
- Oh, yes, they did.
- They gave it up to the enemy?
- Absolutely, the Mujahedin, would go up,
get into a skirmish, a firefight,
lose a guy or two, maybe
kill an Al-Qaeda guy or two,
and then they'd leave.
It was almost like it was an agreement,
an understanding between the
two forces fighting each other,
almost, put on a good
show, and then leave.
- [Scott] In the morning,
bin Laden was on the radio.
The CIA, Delta, and their
Afghan allies were listening.
How did the Afghans react when they heard
from Osama bin Laden on the radio?
- Osama bin Laden is many a Muslim's hero.
These guys, in my
opinion, were more in awe
of Osama bin Laden than they
were willing to kill him.
When they heard him talking on the radio,
they would gather around the individual
that handheld that transistor.
He would hold it up in the air,
almost as if he didn't want
the connection to break,
and almost like they
could see the ridge line
Osama bin Laden happened
to be talking from,
like they could almost see
him and feel his presence.
And they just stood there with wide eyes
and somewhat in awe that here
is a leader of the jihad,
the leader of Al-Qaeda,
and they're actually
hearing his voice over the radio.
- And these were the men who
were supposed to help you
capture or kill him?
Some allies.
And then, something
extraordinary happened.
Fury's Afghan allies announced
that they had negotiated
a ceasefire with Al-Qaeda,
something the Americans
had no interest in.
When Fury's team advanced anyway,
his Afghan partners drew
their weapons on Delta.
It took 12 hours to end
the bogus ceasefire,
precious time for Al-Qaeda to move.
You gotta figure he's
heading for the valley
and to pass into Pakistan.
- Our assumption is he's going
for the valley at that time.
- [Scott] Bin Laden had changed direction
and the tone of his radio calls.
- Clearly under duress, clearly hurting,
clearly caring for his men.
- [Scott] Inside this
building, the American team
listened to bin Laden on the radio.
Fury wrote down the
translation in a notebook.
- Quote, "Our prayers were not answered.
"Times are dire and bad.
"We did not get support from the apostates
"who are our brothers.
"I'm sorry for bringing you here.
"It is okay to surrender," end quote.
- When you heard that, what did you think?
- I thought, it's almost over.
- So Dalton Fury is a pen name.
He has a book, actually several books
called "To Kill bin Laden".
He was the major in
charge of the Delta Forces
in the Afghan operation.
And you can read his book if
you want the detailed account.
But basically what happened at Tora Bora
has been much in dispute.
An important document which
gives a lot of the blow by blow
is this Senate report, foreign
relations Senate report
published in 2009,
which documents a lot of what Fury
said in that clip and that basically
that the US, it's not the
only thing, by the way.
Some might be skeptical of this if you see
who was chairman of the
committee at that time.
And he had failed in his 2004
bid to unseat George W. Bush;
though, he was not involved
in writing this report.
But another, around the
same time, an academic,
you can read this abstract at your leisure
when I post the slides,
basically they said
there was an alternative path not taken,
not just the two strategies
that Fury was suggesting,
feeding up the command
that didn't wanna hear him,
but that there were
even within the ceiling
of 10,000 troops, even
within that ceiling,
there were battle plans
to go into the mountains
and at least seal off
the escape to Pakistan,
and they didn't do it.
Instead, there was a lot of hand-wringing
about whether, first of
all, there were claims
that we didn't know he was there for sure,
which turned out to be false.
The CIA did know that
he was there for sure.
And then they thought that
maybe he had been killed,
and they spent some time
digging up for bodies.
But he hadn't been killed.
The strategy had essentially been
to rely upon these militias
whose loyalty was very much in question.
And of course, we shouldn't
be surprised by that,
not only for the reasons Dalton Fury gave
in that video, that they might have had
much stronger allegiance,
many of those people
to bin Laden than to the
prospect of killing him,
but also because we
know from the literature
on civil wars, here
the state of the art is
Stathis Kalyvas's work, used
to be at Yale, now at Oxford,
but civil wars are never
just about ethnic conflicts.
There are all kinds of other
local interests served.
And as we saw in the
Host Nation Trucking case
we talked about some time ago,
people are being paid and making money
in these kinds of settings.
And so it's very unlikely
that you're gonna be able
in a setting like this
to outsource the fighting
against somebody like bin Laden.
What explains the American strategy?
Well, one is that we wanted to keep
the troops to a minimum.
As I said, there have been
subsequent studies done,
both by the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee
and academic studies
which make it believable,
at least obviously there's always risk
in any military operation,
but there's a colorable case
that the US could have gone in
with troops that were in the region
and prevented bin Laden's escape.
It seems like a principal reason was that
what has become so important
in American wars abroad,
they wanted to keep the number
of US casualties to a minimum.
As you saw, there were only
some 50 Delta Force people
up there in the mountains
working with the Afghans.
They did not want
Americans to start hearing
about dead soldiers in Afghanistan.
But then, secondly, it is
also clear from that report
that they were already
in December of 2001,
President Bush was asking
Rumsfeld for a battle plan
to go into Iraq and remove
Saddam Hussein from power.
And they did not want to
get a lot of American troops
embroiled in any kind of
conflict in Afghanistan.
So the thought was they
were gonna be redeploying
whatever assets they had in Afghanistan
as soon as possible to Iraq.
Now, you might think about, well,
what were the costs of this strategy?
One was the obvious, immediate cost,
that bin Laden and Al-Qaeda
escaped through the mountains
to Pakistan, which gave them
a huge propaganda victory
against the US, that the most
powerful nation on Earth,
in fact, couldn't chase
down this terrorist group
in the mountains of Afghanistan.
But secondly, also because
we had such a weak footprint,
actually Mullah Omar himself escaped
on a motor bicycle, motorcycle
from Afghanistan into Pakistan
and would come to lead
the Taliban insurgency
to retake the country from
the new regime in Kandahar,
so much so that within a
year, American generals
on the ground were saying
up the chain of command,
you should negotiate a
deal with the Taliban
because the new regime's not
gonna be able to survive.
And here we are 18 years later,
and I believe we're on
the verge of doing that.
But they were saying it as early as 2002.
And finally I think that
what the Afghan operation
did do, though it was gonna take some time
for this to become clearer,
it made it obvious the that
gap between the aspirations
for and the capacities
behind the Bush Doctrine
were becoming, it should
say doctrine on that slide,
the Bush Doctrine, were
coming clearly into view,
because if you think about
the massive expansive reach
that we proclaimed, we'll
wage preemptive wars
against gathering threats
anywhere on the world
at any time with any
allies, at the same time,
as we're shrinking our
military capacities,
extremely unwilling to get
American soldiers killed
and wanting to work through proxies,
that this is not gonna end well.
It didn't end well in Afghanistan,
and next Tuesday, we'll
see how it ended in Iraq.
See you then.
(people milling)
(peaceful music)